here today because it's gray out as
opposed to yesterday
it's a pleasure to introduce our next
speaker on the interpretability in law
session
rebecca wexler is an assistant professor
of law and faculty co-director of the
berkeley center for law and technology
at uc berkeley school of law
she works on data technology and secrecy
in the criminal legal system and her
real focus has been on legal doctrines
that limit criminal defense counsel's
ability to scrutinize machine learning
systems
and other new technologies that law
enforcement use to generate and analyze
evidence and criminal cases
rebecca also has
her work is very grounded because she
herself was a public defender for many
years
and so she brings some
i think very important real world
credibility and information into our
discussions and with that i'm gonna
invite rebecca to take it away
okay thank you so much deirdre thanks to
everyone for coming i'm thrilled to be
here
uh
as deirdre said i work
on data and technology and secrecy in
the criminal legal system
so i'm going to start the talk by giving
a brief overview of how these
technologies are coming into the system
and what the legal adversarial process
looks like or should look like
and then i'm going to talk about four
buckets of legal doctrines that can
block
access to information that might be
helpful
for interpretability in machine learning
systems
so
just start
i tested this
and now it works
um
to start
what is the adversarial criminal legal
system
well in the u.s
we rely on law enforcement that's police
and prosecutors
to investigate evidence of guilt and
present that to the jury
and we rely on criminal defense counsel
to investigate evidence of innocence
and present that to the jury as well as
to scrutinize contest challenge probe
question the prosecution's evidence of
guilt
so this is very important to realize
that law enforcement
has zero
constitutional
statutory or ethical obligation
to investigate
evidence of innocence and if there are
flaws in law enforcement's evidence of
guilt that the police and prosecutors
don't know about
they also have zero
duty to disclose that information to the
defense
so the entire system relies on defense
counsel to surface
flaws biases errors fraud
inaccuracy unreliability in prosecution
evidence and that is why we need
something called criminal subpoenas and
this is the process that a defense
counsel would use
to try to access information about a
machine learning system
the outputs of which are being used in
their case against their clients
actually i'm realizing i should give a
little bit of a
background on what kind of systems this
might be
um this could be predictive policing
systems
that
a defendant might challenge as biased or
violating of the equal protection clause
this could be a face recognition or
voice identification systems that police
rely on
the outputs for investigations to search
and sees to arrest somebody or
ultimately also to
introduce those outputs as evidence of
guilt at the trial phase of a case
um so those are a couple of examples but
then later on in the process you might
have risk assessment instruments that
are used to decide whether somebody gets
pre-trial incarceration or sentencing
used to guide sentencing and their slew
of other kinds of technologies you could
imagine
machine learning and not machine
learning the outputs of which could be
introduced to uh search sees arrest or
convict or sentence so criminal
defendants are going to want to test and
scrutinize those systems and they're
going to use this thing called a
subpoena
the subpoena is going to let them
demand information from the developer of
the system
okay so demand information that law
enforcement might not have demand source
code training data
input weights for models um
user manuals
specifications anything you might want
to know about a system you're going to
use the subpoena power to get at the
third party developer and try to compel
disclosure of information
um now another piece of important
background information here is that this
power to compel disclosure is actually
pretty minimal
so it requires these things that you can
only access information that's relevant
you can only access information that's
going to be admissible in your case and
you have to identify the information
with specificity so if you're hearing
this process and you're a developer of
machine learning systems that you sell
to the criminal legal system and you're
getting really worried that defense
counsel might go on a fishing expedition
and try to exploit you to disclose
irrelevant stuff just to raise the costs
or you know create problems for you this
is going to tamper down what defense can
get at any baseline level
on top of that there are doctrines
called
privileges
and privileges add extra secrecy
protections
that can be used to block these defense
subpoenas
and i'm going to spend the rest of the
talk talking about privileges
okay but from the big picture you could
see
we want privileges to be pretty narrow
because they are very
costly
they interfere with the truth seeking
process of the criminal legal system by
suppressing
evidence that would be relevant
that would be admissible and that is
identified with specificity in that
subpoena even though you satisfy all
those things if there's a privilege a
special secrecy power developer can
quash it
all right now my four buckets of secrecy
powers the first one
is trade secret law
so trade secret law is a form of
intellectual property
it is a
protection for information that's
commercially valuable that's also not
generally known in the industry so it's
got to be secret protected by reasonable
confidentiality measures um and to have
economic value by virtue of that secrecy
criminal defendants have been denied
access
to an array of information about
automated systems
some with machine learning some without
based on developers claiming that the
information that defendants seek is a
trade secret
okay so source code again user manuals
even they were denied based on trade
secret arguments
this doctrine of using trade secret law
to block criminal defense access to
information is actually relatively
recent
there are
privileged protections for trade secrets
in civil cases that often arise in
patent disputes and other contract
disputes where trade secrets are at
stake in trade secret misappropriation
suits and what usually happens in those
civil cases
is that the information is disclosed
to the opposing counsel
under a strict protective order to the
opposing expert witness under a strict
protective order that says don't share
this with your client only use it for
purposes of this case don't go publish a
thing on the internet and if you do
we're coming after you for contempt of
court breach of contract you know
ethical violations will get you
disbarred all of those things
but
in the criminal legal system
developers have actually asserted an
even more powerful right to withhold
information
and they've done this in part i believe
because
criminal defense counsel
are not very well equipped to challenge
their trade secret claims
and so you have a huge disparity of
power between the developers lawyers and
the defense counsel's lawyers and the
result is a high risk of over claiming
of secrecy protections when it's not
actually necessary to protect the
developers economic interests the
information could be being disclosed to
defense counsel under a protective order
as it is in civil cases and instead
we're seeing
uh developers successfully entirely
withhold information
that would be relevant
to the criminal defendants case
i started working on that issue a number
of years ago and there has been some
positive reform in my view i i think the
secrecy power should be limited so there
have been state laws passed that
preclude developers of risk assessment
instruments uh this is in idaho from
claiming trade secrets
about those systems to bar defense
access to information there have been a
couple of bills presented in the united
states congress
and in the courts uh defendants have
been able to get some headway in uh
defeating this trade secret uh privilege
which i think is a good thing the fight
has shifted a little bit now to the
scope of protective orders
all right my second bucket
of legal doctrines that can block access
to information you might want for
interpretable machine learning
is privacy
so privacy lots of people are supportive
of privacy privacy is generally
something we care a lot about there's
some privacy legislation pending in the
federal level hope that gets passed
but let me tell you a story about some
of the downsides of privacy
this is a case
from a former colleague of mine at the
legal aid society of new york city
police in new york city jailed a man
we'll call him john doe
for allegedly violating a family court
protective order
the alleged victim
showed police screenshots
of harassing text messages and
recordings of harassing voicemails
whispering texts
that she claimed john doe had sent to
her
and neither the police nor the
prosecution questioned the authenticity
of those screenshots or audio recordings
hence they used this to jail the man
pre-trial somebody jailed pre-trial very
likely that they will
confess
um plead guilty in order to
go home the consequences of being
pre-trial incarcerated you could lose
your job you can't get in touch with
your kids you can lose your housing you
know very high penalty
um in this case this man refused to
plead guilty he claimed innocence and he
told defense counsel my former colleague
that he did not send go text messages he
did not send the voicemail
and so
council
took a random chance and subpoenaed a um
company called spoof card that provides
commercial spoofing services where you
can send a message that appears to come
from somebody else's phone number and lo
and behold this company disclosed
records this is an actual screenshot of
the actual records from the case
redacted
establishing that the alleged victim had
a paid customer account and that she had
used it to disguise
those messages and sent the messages to
herself sent the voicemail to herself
using a voice changing software to make
it sound like a man
and so this case shows why criminal
defense subpoenas matter so much this
was exonerating completely exclupating
evidence an innocent man wrongfully
jailed
um the government would never have
gotten this evidence because it believed
the alleged victim
and crucially the only way
that defense counsel could get it is
that they could subpoena a private
company
for somebody else's private records
this was not a subpoena for the client's
own records it was a subpoena for the
alleged victims records
okay
in a case like that defensiveness two
private companies could be the only
means
to exonerate somebody who's wrongfully
convicted now here comes the bad part
unfortunately
many privacy statutes block precisely
this type of defense subpoena
okay
privacy laws
passed by well-meaning legislatures
sometimes include blanket non-disclosure
provisions they say hey company you've
got sensitive information you're not
allowed to reveal it
and then they have an exception
now i have an exception for law
enforcement
because law enforcement has a powerful
lobby and it goes to the legislature it
says give me an exception and they do
nobody or few people go to the
legislature and say give criminal
defendants an exception so there's a
pattern in privacy laws that
systematically advantages law
enforcement investigations of guilt
as compared to criminal defense
investigations of innocence and i call
these privacy asymmetries
so privacy laws that permit courts to
order disclosure if law enforcement asks
for evidence but not if criminal defense
counsel asks
there's a couple ways that i think these
asymmetries are exacerbated by new uh
machine learning systems
so one is if only the government gets to
access data dumps from social media
accounts for instance or gets to search
biometric databases only the government
gets to benefit from new machine
learning search tools like image
recognition or dna analysis software run
against familial dna databases so one is
who gets to deploy new machine learning
systems
okay if you can't access the data the
deploying of machine learning systems
using data isn't going to be very
helpful to you
similar
access to training data if you wanted
access to training data to scrutinize
machine learning systems
you could run into this asymmetry
um and finally developing machine
learning systems if you need data to
develop new systems and only law
enforcement can access data only law
enforcement's going to develop the
systems
um so all right happy to talk a little
bit more about those later if you're
interested but here's a list oh i think
you can't uh you can't even see all of
them but here's a list of a series of
federal statutes that i um identified
that have these privacy asymmetry so
it's a repeat problem
bucket number three of legal barriers to
accessing information you might need for
interpretable machine learning is
the
law enforcement privilege
so
i p laws we talked about they protect
information for commercial economic
reasons
privacy laws protect information for
dignitary autonomy reasons
other reasons
um
this is a doctrine that protects
information for security reasons
in the domestic law enforcement conduct
context sorry police sometimes say
um we're going to use this investigative
method and we need to keep it secret
even while we rely on the outputs to
arrest somebody or convict them at trial
we need to keep it secret because if it
became generally known people committing
crimes could evade detection so
everybody knows where i put my
surveillance camera they're going to
tamper with it destroy it avoid it
whatever
everybody knows you know how my
remote computer hacking tool exploits a
vulnerability in a network or a device
well that vulnerability is going to get
patched and the exploit's going to go
away and the investigative method is
going to be ineffective at scale
instantaneously
so they say to the courts i'm going to
use this method i'm going to use the
outputs i'm going to introduce the
outputs into evidence in court but i'm
not going to tell you anything about the
method
well that's a problem or i'm not going
to tell you i should say everything
about the method
that's a problem because defense counsel
might want to know
was that method unconstitutional was
that method unlawful was it far more
privacy invasive than law enforcement
claims
or perhaps was it less accurate less
reliable than law enforcement claims and
there's a risk that law enforcement
might be mistaken
in their assertions about how these
things work
they might be
exaggerated in their assertions about
how valuable secrecy is to security
or they might be making protectual
claims to conceal wrongdoing or
negligence they might even be
perpetrating fraud on the court how is
defense counsel uh going to no
so the current doctrine
um that
that resolves these tensions is called
the law enforcement evidentiary
privilege basically defense counsels
subpoenas
police departments or they might
subpoena the private developer of a
surveillance software system or you
could imagine a maybe it's a face
matching system or a voice
identification system that if everybody
knew how it worked they could create an
adversarial um
[Music]
attack that would allow people to evade
identification so they could be
subpoenaing the developer or law
enforcement and they're going to say i
need that information for my
motion to argue this is unconstitutional
or unlawful or inaccurate law
enforcement's going to say to the court
no this is a secret law enforcement
method that needs to remain secret to be
effective and the court will have to
balance those things so a generalist
judge
generalist judge
will have to assess whether they believe
law enforcement specialists
analysis of how important secrecy is to
security
and then if they do believe it
they will have to balance
the risks to law enforcement's method
against
defendant's interest and access
so
you may not be surprised to learn that
most of these cases the generalist judge
differs to the law enforcement claim
and so most of these cases
end up in
ongoing secrecy
around the law enforcement method
um okay my final legal doctrine that
well let's see i think i have time i'll
just i'll um
i'll show you these two folks because i
think they're kind of interesting and
they give some background on this
privilege um but but okay so just gives
a little bit of uh a sense of how
embedded this power is in our law
but this is a guy named bishop atterbury
and he is uh uh was tried for treason in
england in the 17th century
and the uh law enforcement agency there
sees some letters from the mail that
were encrypted and then got a expert
witness to decrypt them
and lo and behold the expert witness got
up on the witness stand and said the
contents of this letter basically say hi
i'm bishop atterbury and i'm guilty of
teresa so let's convict him and sentence
them to death
and the defense said gee i don't think
that was an accurate decryption method
i'd like to contest that
would you tell me how you did the
decryption and the witness said no
that's a secret law enforcement
investigative method and if i told you
future criminals would create more
robust um ciphers and make it harder for
us to decrypt
so the court in england this is a 17th
century court in england says okay no
problem we're going to let that witness
testify and we're not going to require
disclosure of the methods
and the defense tough have a good time
trying to cross-examine and impeach
they did eventually convict him
i believe he was
initially
given some kind of expedition that he
could have instead of a death sentence
and then um and then later
maybe
um and executed
next one this is a woman named judith
koplin and uh she this is the united
states so fast forward this is the
united states um at the height of the
cold war and she was convicted of
passing national security secrets to a
soviet spy
lots and lots of evidence against her
she was definitely guilty of this crime
and uh the fbi admitted
that they had engaged in some illegal
wiretapping during the course of the
investigation
but they promised i promise
none of the evidence we introduced at
trial was actually the result of this
illegal wiretapping
the um
uh
fbi the defense wanted access to the
fbi's wiretap records um and the fbi
actually uh claimed this privilege to
to withhold them now the judge in this
case upheld the privilege and said there
is this privilege it does exist it could
apply to these wiretap records in that
particular instance the fbi had waived
the secrecy power for another reason
but this was overall a u.s late 20th
century or mid-20th century endorsement
of the same secrecy power that the
government in england had used in the
17th century to convict bishop atterbury
all right my last uh legal doctrine that
i wanted to flag for us is contract law
and this is um getting a little bit
personal
because i have been working with some
colleagues ready
andrea roth in the law school
to try to access
and license
an executable copy of a dna analysis
software system
that's being used now to convict people
at trial
and despite the developer telling courts
across the country
that this software system is subject to
peer review
the developers
have refused to provide us with a
research license where we could engage
in testing and scrutiny of the system
and so
companies can use their licensing powers
and contract powers to
distort
who gets access to scrutinized systems
or preclude uh scrutiny altogether
so i think i've got
five minutes for
my questions if that's
um if that's a thing that we do
it is indeed
um and i don't see any in the chat but
folks in the chat if you would like to
put questions in if you're online and
otherwise i'm going to turn it over to
zach or ben who are in the room
for any questions from the auditorium
uh the thanks rebecca that was
fascinating uh so i have a question
about uh
i suppose political economy of evidence
especially with the notion of relevance
that you were discussing in the
beginning
and how that might interact with
technical definitions of some legal and
ethical terms
that are kind of might be of interest to
us so
the type of thing that i have in mind is
something like fairness right
in some technical work it's defined in a
very narrow way
in terms of the properties of the model
and many people have contested that and
said that that's not the right
definition we have to adopt a kind of
broader perspective to really see
issues of unfairness and discrimination
so
depending on which definition we adopt
certain things become relevant or
irrelevant as information that pertains
to the case
so do you think these like these voices
are there out there and uh kind of
about which definitions been in the
technical literature and how that might
impact
uh the victims of these type of
technologies to actually contest the
decisions that are made about them
yeah really interesting uh issue
so i let me start by giving the legal
definition of relevance
whichever definition of fairness it ends
up going to
relevance in law is a very
it's a low bar
um it's it's you know it narrows things
in that you can't go on a totally uh
unbounded fishing expedition to harass
or abuse and try to just get access to
information just because
it has to be relevant but what is
relevant means it means any information
that makes a fact at issue
more
or less likely
than it would be
without the information
so it doesn't have to prove something
it only has to incrementally make the
thing
more or less likely
and then this goes to your um that's if
you want a site federal rule of evidence
401
um if this goes now to the next stage um
what's the definition that's at issue
because it has to be more or less likely
um than it would be without the evidence
but the fact has to be a fact at issue
in the case and so i think your point
about how we define fairness
is going to go to what's at issue in the
case and that would be a legal question
rather than an evidence question
um is you know what's an appropriate
uh system to use um what is um
a system is you know sufficiently say
contestable to satisfy a defendant's
confrontation rights or rights to
cross-examination uh what kind of system
is
um sufficiently unbiased to pass the
equal protection clause
and one of the interesting things about
having these conversations across csn
law
is that
[Music]
it will be courts
that finally decide
which
characteristics of a system
matter for
the
equal protection or constitutional
rights analysis so i think what the
technology technological community can
do is present an array of options and
argue to courts about which ones they
should pick why uh they should rely on
one or or the other but ultimately will
be courts that decide
this brings me a very fascinating talk
thank you very much
this brings me to a question that has
been bothering me for quite a while and
that's
how technologically savvy are the judges
do they understand the meaning of
statistical evidence do they understand
the meaning of peer review do they
understand the the meaning of a
confidence of a prediction i mean
and is there any way to improve it yeah
well this is one of the huge challenges
of the legal system as a whole you know
the short answer is
no they don't understand it the better
answer is
that's okay
because
generalist judges aren't expected to be
experts in any of the things that they
rule on they're not expected to be
experts in
even the legal areas that they rule on
rather they're expected to be educated
by the adversary process
so they're expected to
learn and inform themselves of complex
facts statistical evidence buy a battle
of the experts from both sides now i'm
not saying it's a perfect system i
assure you all some of you may have done
expert testimony you know that there's
all sorts of problems with it but that
is the system that the legal system has
chosen to rely on so the problem with
generalist judges not knowing how to
second guess a security expert how to
decide if something's really a national
security secret how to anal analyze
statistical evidence the way our legal
system responds to that problem is to
acknowledge it and say our solution is
adversarialism
but this gets to another little um
variation
which is that for secrecy doctrines like
the ones i'm talking about trade secret
privacy
uh law enforcement security secrecy
national security secrecy
the doctrines themselves
rob
judges of the benefits of adversarialism
because they require judges to make
determinations alone in chambers with
only the party claiming secrecy present
otherwise determining if the secrecy
claim is valid
would expose the secret in the process
of assessing its legitimacy okay so
there's this extra complication for
adjudicating secrecy claims that are
complex if you have a statistical
evidence issue that goes to whether this
law enforcement method actually is
so sensitive it needs to be secret to be
effective then we're really in trouble
and i don't know what to do about that
but i i'm going to say that's the worst
of the scenarios
uh rebecca maybe one last question
um in some of your work you've talked
about kind of
both the benefit of validation studies
code review
other kind of expert evaluations of
systems but also their limits
and in particular the ways in which
those limits i think arise from kind of
the ways in which different venues value
different sorts of expertise and account
for different sorts of evidence which
reflect kind of different value
commitments and i was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about
that in this context
oh really interesting yeah so there's
been so as an example what you're just
saying and and thank you for the
um the question uh you know for instance
there's a big debate a lot of defense
counsel
in different cases have sought source
code to scrutinize for computer systems
that generate evidence used at trial
and then there's a big debate about
whether the source code is
necessary
to understand how the thing works or
validate it or know if it's reliable
whether it's
useful
whether it's the most efficient or
effective way to assess these things
and so i see a lot of times when defense
counsel make motions for source code
people say oh they're you know they're
making motion for the wrong thing
um a better way to go about it for
instance would be uh they should be
demanding black box validation studies
as deirdre hinted at however
there are other values built into the
legal process
that say
defense counsel
is the one who should choose
how they prove their case
so even if defense counsel is going
about asking for something that's maybe
not necessary
maybe not even the most efficient or
best way of scrutinizing a system
unless there's a
darn good reason to block them
with a secrecy interest we
have a commitment to letting defense
counsel choose how they want to do their
job
we don't like the idea of outsiders
experts certainly not the prosecution
academics anybody else telling counsel
how to represent their clients
so that's what would be an example i
think of what you're bringing up to your
job thank you for the question
thanks thanks everybody
great um i think we're going to end
there in part because i think it's a
great setup for alexandra's talk
um where we can kind of dig in a little
bit more about
interpretability as
you know
what kind of value is it is it really
something that's intrinsic or is it
really something that's instrumental and
who determines
um and
i think we're moving straight into
alexandra's presentation is that right i
can't